[موسيقى]
لطالما كان تلوث الهواء مشكلة
حاول الكثيرون حلها
، ومع وفاة ما يقدر بنحو 7 ملايين شخص
قبل الأوان
كل عام نتيجة لتلوث الهواء ،
فإن السباق مستمر لإيجاد حل شركة
airlabs هي شركة مقرها المملكة المتحدة
متخصصة في  تكنولوجيا الهواء النظيف
وإدارة جودة
الهواء طورت مختبرات الهواء تقنية رائدة محتملة
تُعرف باسم فقاعة الهواء ،
وتهدف تقنية فقاعة الهواء إلى
تنظيف كمية كبيرة من الهواء ، لذلك
نحن نتحدث عن
30000 لتر في الساعة وهو أمر ضخم حقًا
[موسيقى
] الهدف حقًا هو معالجة أكبر
قدر ممكن من الهواء مع وجود منتج
صغير بما يكفي ليناسب
الجزء الداخلي من المركبات أعلاه
واستنزاف التكنولوجيا التي نستخدمها ، وهو في
الواقع فعال للغاية ،
لذا فنحن نزيل ما يصل إلى 95
من الملوثات و  مسببات الأمراض نقوم أيضًا
بإزالة ملوثات الغاز ولأن
التركيز في الوقت الحالي ينصب على
الجسيمات الدقيقة وفيروس كورونا
وما هي
تكلفة امتلاك وتركيب أحد هذه
الأجهزة التي تستهدفها بالضبط هل
يمكن أن يكون لدي واحد في منزلي على سبيل المثال ،
نعم يمكنك التكلفة الإجمالية
أه يعتمد على هل تشتريها مباشرة أو
هل تأخذ خدمة الاشتراك الخاصة بك
حيث
نعم نقدمها بما في ذلك
بدائل الفلتر العادية ولكن إذا  إذا كنت تفكر في
النقل العام ،
فستفكر ربما عشرين
دولارًا شهريًا أو ما شابه ذلك
كتكلفة تشغيل ، لذا ربما
تتحدث عن أقل من دولار واحد في اليوم ،
مهمتنا هي لعب دور رائد
في الحد من تعرض الناس
لتلوث الهواء.
ملتزمون بمواصلة
تطوير التكنولوجيا التي تتعامل من ناحية
مع الطبيعة المتطورة لتلوث الهواء
بالإضافة إلى جعل هذه التقنيات
أكثر كفاءة في استخدام الطاقة وتنتج نفايات أقل